The best way I think to
introduce the central issues of,
of this wonderful poem was it us is,
is to return to, to Milton's
Comus. So yet, once more,
and I promise this will be one of the
last times that we look back at Milton's
mask, but once yet, once more,
let's look at a comas now.
You will remember that the Mass Komas was
everywhere concerned with questions of
the power of will.
The strangely intertwined questions of
the power of chastity on the one hand in
the power of poetry on the other,
the two brothers in the, in the,
in the mask engaged in that philosophical
debate about the force or the strength
of,
of virginity.
And the second brother you'll remember
had taken what I take to be the perfectly
reasonable position, the cautious
position that the ladies endangers,
that she's a sitting duck.
In fact,
out there in the dangerous forest.
And uh,
it was, uh, it was, uh,
according to the second brother,
it's virtually impossible for a single
helpless maiden to pass uninjured in this
wild surrounding waste.
Now, the elder brother,
we remember hastily dismissed
his brother's pessimism.
And any insisted that the ladies virginity
was fully capable of protecting her
from any such physical attack.
Now did the extent that this, uh,
this discussion discussion is
actually about the virginity of,
of the younger brother and the
elder brother, sister. It, it,
it seems, I think to to border
on the, on the ridiculous,
but the debate I think we
have to take seriously.
It's an important one for Milton and it's
important because it touches on a lot
of them. Uh, more consequential questions.
And I'm thinking of
the general problem of,
of the abstraction of virtue,
the,
an abstract notion of virtue and,
and think of all the questions that
all of us at some point or other I
tend to associate with virtue is,
is virtuous behavior repaid
with some kind of ultimate good?
Are we rewarded for our virtue
and for our virtuous deeds? Are,
are we recompensed in some way for all
of those sacrifices that we make in the
name of virtue,
these are questions that Milton will
never stop asking and that he will never
stop attempting to answer.
And the position that Milton,
this is how I like to read it,
this the,
the position that Milton would like
to be able to take on this question of
virtues. Reward is formulated by
the elder brother in Comas and I'm,
I'm thinking of the passage near the
bottom of page 103 in the Hughes.
This is comas line 588 the elder brother,
so the brother says virtue may
be a sailed but never hurt.
Surprised by unjust force
but not in throat. Yeah.
Even that which mischief meant most shell
in the happy trial proved most glory
but evil on itself.
Shell back recoil and mix
no more with goodness.
When it last gathered like
scum and settled to itself,
it shall be in eternal restless change,
self fed and self consumed.
Okay.
If this fail,
the pillared firmament is rottenness
and earth space built on stubble.
Okay.
Virtue invariably protects itself.
Virtue is in variably rewarded
with glory and evil a,
and this is the, this is the flip side
of the coin. Evil is always punished.
It's gathered like in this,
this amazing image.
It's gathered like scum in some eternal
cess pool where itself fed and self
consumed a problem solved.
And the elder brother
continues though if this fail
okay.
By which he means if virtue does not in
every single instance trial a triumph
over evil,
then this is a world whose heaven,
who's pillared firmament is rotten to
the core and whose base or who's found
who's very foundation
is nothing but stumble.
If virtue fails to triumph
over evil than what, uh,
then this simply isn't a war,
a world worth living in. Uh,
that's, that's what I take the,
the, the elder brother to mean here.
These are unquestionably strong words and
I think it's impossible for us to over
mate over estimate the weight of these
words that the speech is more than just a
pious bit of optimism.
Like a lot of the speeches in fact that
the elder brother has given us. Um,
and we have to confess, I'm,
it's, it's more than that.
This speech is a challenge.
The elder brother is challenging God to
see to it that some kind of justice is
actually effected on this,
on this earth.
And so I'm going to be
placing a particular amount
of pressure on this passage
because this is the first
expense expression and
Milton have a very particular
kind of argument of a religious argument.
And it,
it's one that becomes central
to all of paradise lost. Uh,
the speech of the elder brothers is a
theodicy and theodicy is the term coined
by the 18th century
philosopher live minutes, uh,
which he had any applied
this term theodicy to just
that kind of philosophical
sentiment that's,
that's implied by its etymology that the
Odyssey is an account of the justice,
the decay of God a Theo or theos.
And so do you use the words with which
Milton would begin? Paradise lost.
A theodicy is an attempt to
justify the ways of God to men
know for a lot of Orthodox
Christians in Milton's time.
And I think we can say the same for a lot
of Orthodox Christians in our own time
to embark upon anything like a,
at all can be considered a heretical,
or at the very least Hetero
docs. A theodicy can be, uh,
can be seen as heretical
or even blasphemous for the
simple reason that it is.
Think of what it is zooms.
It assumes that the ways of
God are in fact justifiable.
A theodicy assumes that God's justice
can be witnessed and that it can be
accounted for here on,
on earth.
A theodicy assumes that the things that
things on earth actually makes sense and
that God's ways are ultimately
rationally accessible,
that they are comprehensible by human
beings and that God can in some way.
And this is, I think the, the central
implication of the elder brother here,
that God can in some way
be held accountable for his
actions to justify the ways
of God to men is essentially to put
God on trial for the actions that he
performs. And in the, of course,
in the central test case,
this is what we all care about for the
unfortunate events that befall virtuous
people.
The next major poem that,
that Milton Rights after comas is
listed as you'll remember that, uh,
Milton published comas and 1637 and uh,
and it's 1637 later that same year that
Milton rights listeners and enlisted as
Milton looks back at the elder brothers
theodicy and it's almost as if he's a
attempting to test its validity. Uh, you,
you can think of Milton asking in this
poem, listeners asking if it's true,
is it true with the elder brother said
that virtue is all raise were awarded and
evil punished.
Now listen to us.
[inaudible] this is
undeniable is a stencil oddly,
and maybe more than ostensibly it's an LG.
It's a poem about a depth.
It mourns the loss of a friend of, of,
of Milton's from, from Cambridge. Uh,
the young man was named Edward King and
he drowned in a shipwreck and the Irish
sea shortly before he took up orders as
a minister for the Church of England.
And like so many,
and I mentioned this before,
like so many of the young men
studying with Milton and Cambridge,
a king was being prepared to
pursue a career in the church.
Now, and I don't think this
is unimportant, king was also,
it would seem he was also a minor poet,
an amateur poet.
I'm like Milton he wrote versus uh,
there there's,
there's nothing like a shred of evidence
that to suggest that a Edward King had
any talent whatsoever. Nonetheless, the
fact that he attempted to be a poet, um,
I think is important here.
Edward King in fact seems to have been
sufficiently well liked or admired that,
that when news of his death hit Cambridge,
a group has been as friends
organize something like an
anthology of poems in his
honor. And this is on the handout. The,
the title of the book is
a juice dot Eduardo King.
Now Fraga obsequies on Edward
King lost at sea or drowned.
And now we have no evidence that king
was a particularly close friend of
Milton's. But nonetheless,
Milton was as an ambitious, uh,
literary figure in college.
Uh,
he was asked to contribute some verses
to the anthology and listened to us is
the product of that request.
And we shouldn't be surprised that
Milton has to be compelled to write this
poem. He's still in that awkward phase
of unreadiness and under preparation.
Now, readers have always seemed to have
agreed that that Melton's listened.
This is an enormously admirable poem,
but for a few hundred years now,
there has been a controversy over
how admirable Milton's listen,
this is specifically as an elegy, that
the poem is obviously magisterial. It's,
it's, it's moving. And, uh, just about
everyone concedes that at many junctures,
it's a, it's, it's, it's,
it's extraordinarily, uh,
it's extraordinarily learned.
It's obviously learn it,
but it's also very moving.
This is the question now,
is it properly elegiac is listed as a,
an appropriate expression of grief over
the death of Edward King and does it
furthermore,
does it console others for their
grief over Edward King's death?
Now this is a,
this is a debate that fits into the same
category as far as I'm concerned as the
one between the elder and the
second brother. Uh, this is,
this is a debate that will
forever and forever be fruitless,
uh, because it's
unanswerable. Um, nonetheless,
I still think there's something about
this controversy surrounding this poem.
The poem as analogy that, that, that we
need to take is instructive because if,
if Milton's,
listen,
this isn't an expression of grief over
the death of King Edward King than just
what this is what we have to ask.
Then just what is it an expression of?
So
let us,
let us begin our exam examination
of this question with a,
with a consideration of the poems form.
Now,
the most distinguishing feature of,
of Milton's allergies,
the fact that it's a pastoral LNG,
it engages the ancient art of
pastoral poetry, uh, initiated,
made, made famous by the, the
great Greek poet theocracy,
which was later into imitated by Moscow.
And then finally by the Roman poet Virgil
in his celebrated pastoral EKG logs.
And you can see on the handout of those
poems by those classical authors that,
that Milton's listened to us is,
is most indebted to
the pastoral.
Lg is clearly one of the most stylized
and most self consciously artificial of
all of the poetic genres.
The,
the poet of a pastoral log usually
represents himself as a shepherd,
a shepherd mourning the
death of a fellow shepherd.
And he often explains that the
death of these shepard friend is,
is exerting a magical effect
on the entire natural world.
This is called the pathetic
fallacy. The trees, the rocks,
the streams are all weeping for
the loss of the shepherd speakers,
a beloved companion. And it's at
this point in the pastoral allergy,
the conventional stereotypical pastoral
allergy that the poet Shepard sings a
mournful song.
He sings this song and Itchy in which
he recalls all those happy days that he
had spent with his shepherd
friend in the countryside.
So we have, uh, we have in the
pastoral LLG a generic form that's,
that's highly predictable
and it has not only,
not only now,
but I think on some level it has
always struck some of its readers as,
as ludicrous and, and we're not being
merely churlish. I think, um, if,
if we want to ask why,
why someone would want to write a
poem in such a form. Um, it, it, it,
as you can imagine,
it had long been out of fashion in
Milton zone day that the pastoral genre,
in fact, even for theocracies,
it's inventor, uh,
was always highly artificial.
A theocracy,
new know more about shepherds or sheep
or shepherd ases or Nymphs and seders
than you are. I know. And later urban
poets and [inaudible] was an urban poet.
Later urban poets like Virgil or Milton
Milton Hour Londoner knew even less than
theocracies.
We have to assume it's all,
it's almost as if the entire point of
a pastoral is that it is set in a world
that neither the urbane poet nor the
urbane reader has actually any real
experience with,
uh,
another way into this problem.
Let's look at the comments
that Dr. Johnson made about
Milton's listed as in the
18th century.
Um,
this is reading from the packet assigned
for today and I'm going to ask you, uh,
to do what you can to get through the
biography of Milton in the packet as well
as the notes on Milton's poetry that
we have from Dr. Samuel Johnson.
Uh, make sure you will have done
that by the midterm. Okay. Uh,
famously Dr. Johnson
couldn't bear this poem.
Listen us. Um, Dr. Johnson, the, the,
the greatest of all literary
critics of the 18th century.
And because Milton's poem is probably
considered to be the most important leg
written in any language by any poet
Johnson's assessment of it has become
famous, uh, for,
for being one of the most wrongheaded
evaluations ever made of a work of
literature by a great literary critic,
but inspired wrong headedness,
which is what I take a, which is what
I take Dr. Johnson to be guilty of,
is invaluable.
And so I want to quote Dr. Johnson here.
And this is on the handout.
Listen to us is not to be considered as
the effusion of real passion for passion
runs not after remote
illusions and obscure opinions.
Passion plucks,
no berries from the myrtle and Ivy
Norcos upon Erath who's and [inaudible]
Nortel's of rough seders and Fonz with
cloven heal where there is leisure for
fiction,
there is little grief,
it's form the form of the pastoral.
Lg is that the form of lists
of this is that of a pastoral,
easy,
vulgar and therefore disgusting.
Now I have to say,
although the last word is obviously
incredibly powerful and sort of wonderful,
it doesn't have quite
the punch that it does.
It didn't have quite the punch 'em in
the 18th century that it has for us now.
Disgusting really means literally
for Johnson merely distasteful.
It's still,
these are still strong words and there
has to be something more here than merely
Johnson's massive blunder.
As a literary critic.
Johnson tells us that,
listen,
this is not to be considered as the fusion
of real passion for passion runs not
after remote illusions
and obscure opinions.
And it's difficult to imagine
that an expression of,
of genuine grief over the death
of a genuinely close friend would,
would take the form of a poem
of a poem so learned, uh,
so filled with remote literary
allusions and obscure, obscure opinions.
Johnson obviously has a as a point here,
but we have to remember that king himself
was a poet or thought of himself as a
poet. He was a poet who died
before he could take up his career.
And it's not unlikely
that he wasn't married,
that he was also a poet who died
while he was still a virgin.
King's death provides Milton with an
occasion on which Milton is able to write
the most personal poem,
uh,
that he has yet written and
perhaps that he will ever right.
He gets to ask all of those questions
that are most pressing to him.
John Milton.
Uh,
what if the virgin of Milton were to
die before he was able to take up his
career? What if he died before he
was able to fulfill his promises?
The poet before he could
publish or make public his,
his talent.
The very structure in fact of Milton's
poem here is what Dr. Johnson would be
obliged to call a remote an illusion.
The poem is based most closely
on Virgil's 10th o'clock.
This is the poem in which the speaker
grieves over a death by imagining a
procession of mourners after the funeral.
And this really provides the,
the central rhetorical based for Milton's.
Listen,
US and the speaker of the poem mourns
the death of the shepherd poet listed us
and describes this parade,
this procession of mourners who
make their tribute to the deceased.
So look at line. Uh, I'll just, I'll,
I'll run through some of the
central sections here. Um,
line 76 to 84 we have the god of poetry.
Fiba Sapelo himself who
makes an appearance in he
chides Milton for being so
concerned with earthly fame.
Uh, more on that later, uh,
line 88, the next section
Triton the herald of the sea,
he tries, he tries to make sense of listed
as his death. He asked the gods what,
what has happened to listen to us and,
and who exactly was
responsible for the sinking of,
of listed as his ship at [inaudible]. Then
in the next line, the next four lines,
we have Caymus, uh, the god
of the River Cam appears.
He Rem presents Cambridge
University, the Alma Mater, uh,
where Edward King and John Milton
had been students. And finally, uh,
at line lines 108 through 131,
we have Saint Peter,
he of the pearly gates,
Peter bursts onto the scene
and we have without question,
he's the most terrifying of all of the
mourners and in, and he gives an angry,
powerful vitriolic speech about
the terrible state of England,
the terrible state of
the Church of England.
And as a consequence of the
terrible state of England in 1637.
So the structure of this poem is
on an unquestionably Virgilian,
but the sentiments that are voiced and
this poem are unquestionably miltonic and
we will recognize them.
Um, who went Milton,
uh, could speak the poems.
Famous opening lines
turned to the beginning of looseness,
yet once more OEE laurels and once
more you Myrtle's brown with Ivy,
never see her.
I come to pluck your berries harsh
and crude and with forced fingers,
rude, shatter your leaves
before the mellowing year.
Bitter Constraint and sad occasion,
dear compels me to disturb your season.
Do for listeners is dead,
dead air.
His Prime Milton is lamenting once again
that Milton has been compelled to begin
writing.
Okay.
So Edward King had died and the editor
of the Edward King memorial anthology has
pressed Milton and to service what,
what could the young poet do?
Bitter constraint and sad occasion
are forcing, forcing him to write,
even though of course he is not yet ready.
The laurels and the hurdles
that he had that he addresses.
Here are of course the traditional
plants classically associated with,
with great poets, but for Milton and
his passage. Importantly, these plants.
Okay. These plants simply
aren't ripe yet. They're,
their berries are still harsh and crude
and they haven't yet had time to develop.
And Milton is telling us
that he is himself in the
process still in the process
of maturing. He's not yet up to
the task of a great poem yet.
And the only fingers with which you'll
be able to hold his pen and write this
poem are his forced fingers.
Rude.
Now you're right, you're right.
If you had the feeling that,
that you've heard a lot
of these same ideas before
Milton's, nearly 29 years old,
when he writes lists at us, uh, he,
he's making exactly the same disclaimer
that he had made in sonnet seven, uh,
or member sonnet seven. How
soon halftime, the song,
the Sonnet that he had written on the
sad occasion of his 23rd birthday,
uh,
that Milton had claimed there,
that he seemed to have all the outward
appearances of an adult male of a man,
but an inward ripeness
death, much less appear. His,
his poetic talent,
his poetic promise is poetic ripeness.
It hasn't yet burgeoned are
made itself manifest. Well,
this is six years later, six years
later when Milton rights solicitous.
He's is he,
he's employing this scene,
fiction of unreadiness and with filled
with all have the same anxiety of under
preparedness as insulin at seven
Milton rights. The first verse,
paragraph of this, of this
great poem. Uh, listen to us,
the first 14 lines in the
form of a Sonnet, essentially
the form of a sonnet and,
and the lines have a distinctly
a sonnet rhyme scheme, but,
but look closely,
it's not a perfect sonnet in quite the
same way that sign at number seven was a
look at line number four, which is
so clearly simply by looking at this,
you can tell it's deficient in the number
of syllables and there were only six
syllables heal rather than rather
than the, the, the conventional 10.
And it's this line and with
forced fingers rude, it's,
this is called a broken line or a half
line. And this broken line has, has been,
has been read,
I think rightly as Milton's indication
to his reader that he's not even up to
the task of writing a
Sonnet at this point.
Anything he writes is going to be forced
compelled and with his forced fingers
rude.
He violates the formal presiding,
the metrical scheme of his
leg at it's very opening,
just like Edward King who
died before his prime.
Milton has to write this poem
before his own poetic prime.
And so it is with this deeply apologetic,
intensely hesitant beginning the John
Milton opens what many considered to be
the greatest poem in the English language.
The fact that the death here enlisted us
is the death of a young virgin poet at
the very outset of his career,
as you can imagine,
resonates in a lot of powerful ways.
The very idea that if figures so virtuous
could have been dealt such a tragic
and early death strikes, strikes
Milton or Melton speaker here as the,
as the rankest injustice. And it's
this sense of injustice that keeps, uh,
keeps pushing this log in the direction
of a theodicy and attempt to justify the
ways of God.
Milton has to justify or
at least understand this
seemingly incomprehensible and
unjustifiable event.
And it's this drive to theodicy
that accounts for the poems.
Most painful moments.
Look at line 15,
this is where Milton asks the ocean nims,
the ocean nims where they were when
Edward King's boat was lost while crossing
the Irish sea. Why, why
didn't you do anything?
We're worrying hymns when the
remorseless deep closed door,
the head of your loved listen to us,
if you loved listed as so much, how
could you, how could you let him die?
And no sooner has the, the speaker
asked this question and, and,
and you see this rhythm, this dynamic, uh,
a peer continually
throughout restlessness.
He asks the question and then immediately
he acknowledges the inadequacy of the
question. Look at line
55. I me, I fondly dream.
Had you been there for four?
What could that have done?
The nymphs of course are powerless and
we're seeing that the Nymphs as we know,
and of course as John Milton new are
merely fictions. This is all made up.
It's folly to think that we have about
us protective spirits who might actually
keep us from harm. And, and,
and, and Milton continues.
What could the news herself that Orpheus
bore the Muse herself for her and
chanting son,
whom universal nature did lament when
by the route that made the hideous roar,
his glory visage down the stream was sent
down the swift Hebrews to the lesbian
shore. Why, why after all,
should we expect the Nymphs to have
helped poreless at us? Not even the news.
Calliope the abused at that big poetry
was in a position to avert a human
tragedy like this.
Calliope hadn't even been able to,
to save her son the poet Orpheus when
the terrifying Bach I had torn his body
limb from limb when the terrifying
Buckeye had sent his head rolling down the
heat Reese river all the
way to the isle of Lesbos.
If, uh, if you've read a load
leg Ronelle Pencil Rosso, you,
you know that the image of
the great methodological poet,
Orpheus is always a
loaded one from Milton.
This is a myth that has and
will continue to haunt Milton.
I'm all the way up through
paradise lost. Um, let, let, let,
let's have a little review of the
career of the great poet Orpheus. Um,
as, as we get it certainly in a low
light grow and you'll pencil Rosso.
Orpheus was the poet who had attempted
to bring his wife your receipt back from
the underworld. And he did that
by charming Pluto with his song.
The attempt failed and saddened by your
[inaudible] death or Orpheus spent the
rest of his life avoiding
the company of women.
He kept himself solitary and chased.
He devoted himself to poetry.
He sang songs of such beauty that the
entire natural world w would move and
dance in response.
This is the story of Orpheus that we have
received up to this point in Milton's
poetry.
This is the story of the empowerment of
the poet is his empowerment through his
experience of a terrible loss.
And clearly this is a myth that Milton
is identifying with a very strongly here,
but the subject of, listen, this isn't
about, isn't the empowerment of the poet.
It's about the untimely death of a poet.
And so when the figure of
Orpheus appears in this poem,
it's the second half of the Orpheus
story that Milton is forced to tell,
or if he is devotes himself to his
beautiful poetry and he keeps himself
sexually abstinent. He rejects all
of the advances of the, of the,
of the women who are attracted to him,
but the Pecan contest,
the the female followers of the God
Bacchus or enraged by what they take to be
his coyness,
they drown out.
Or if he has his music with the hideous
roar of their housings and their
screenings and they
tear him limb from limb,
the chaste poet
was unable to pass on injured
in that wild surrounding waste.
This violence was so terrible
that not even his mother,
the Muse calliope could
save him or if you said,
provided Milton with a paradigm of
the poet, the poet who's disciplined,
who's abstinence, nourished and
strengthened his poetry and, and,
or if he isn't a lot of ways seemed
like the perfect model of a poet
because he had the power to
do something with his poetry.
His verse actually had a physical impact
on the world. The rocks, the woods. Uh,
the trees danced in
response to Orpheus is music
in comas. Uh, the,
the lady had identified with Orpheus that
she described to comas what her speech,
what her speech about virginity would do.
Um,
if she were actually to deliver it,
if she,
she would bring all of comas is
magic structures down his head,
down around his head.
It's just this orphaned power that Milton,
like the lady was,
was always anticipating for himself.
He's been waiting and waiting
for his season, do so,
so that he can ripen into
a powerful or thick poet.
How then can we justify
the ways of God to man?
How can we justify the fact
that the abstinent or fee,
the virtuous Orpheus was so brutally
assaulted and without it any aid from the
higher powers,
it would seem that the elder brother and
his sister were way too optimistic in
their assessment of the protected
status of the virtue of the,
of the virtuous poet, the protected status
of the Virgin, the favored role of the,
uh, of the poet. Virginity does
nothing. Virtue does nothing.
Poetry does nothing.
All of the self discipline.
And all of the self denial
in the world can do nothing.
This seems to be one of the implications
of this poem can do nothing to protect
the poet from an untimely death.
It's at this moment that the poem reaches
a remarkable climax and I have to say
that this is actually only one of the
poems. Remarkable climax is there. This,
this, this, this poem has amazing
ebbs and flows throughout,
throughout its entirety,
but without question.
This is one of the intensivist
personal moments in the elegy.
Look at line 64 here we have Milton
asking himself all of those questions,
all of those vocational
questions that this fact,
the fact of Edward King's
death seems to open up for him.
Alas.
What boots it
with incessant care to tend the homely
slided shepherds trained and strictly
meditate.
The thankless Muse were it not better
done as others use to sport with Amaryllis
in the shade or with the tangles
of Nina Ira's hair. The the,
the, I think these lines at this
point, I'm going to read them again.
They're too important simply
to have been read once a last,
what boots it with incessant care to
tend the homely slided shepherds trained
and strictly meditate.
The thankless muse were it not butter,
better done as others use to sport
with Amaryllis in the shade or with the
tangles of knee IRA's hair at this
point in our reading of Milton,
I think these lines have
an amazing impact. We, we,
we've spent a couple of weeks now
reading Milton's declarations of the
importance of the shepherds trade.
This is the,
the vocation of poetry
in this pastoral lexicon.
Nielsen's just written, uh, your, your,
you remember he's written his father
and odd pod trim that the trade,
the vocation of poetry. It may be
homely and slided in his father's eyes,
but it was of course worth
all of Milton's time.
All of Milton's unsettlement care and
investment and now Milton's in the
position of asking what for. Look,
look, what's this all about? Look
what happened to Edward King.
What's the point of all of this study?
All of this work, all of this scent,
self-denial. If I could just wind up,
it's a, it's a, this is a good question.
If I could just wind up dead tomorrow and,
and now that I'm in,
now that I'm thinking of it,
why deny myself sexually?
Wha why deny myself physical gratification
if I could just instead a sport with
Amaryllis in the shade or with
the tangles of knee, IRA's,
hair and Milton's asking in these lines,
not simply about actual
erotic entanglements,
but although I think that's there
a relation with women, but it's a,
it's a question about
erotic poetry as well.
Why can't he write love poetry,
secular poetry instead of
this much more discipline,
much more difficult mode of sacred and
prophetic poetry that he seems already to
have weathered himself too.
What's the point of making
life so hard for himself?
Look, now, and this is on the,
this is on the handout at the,
at the letter that Milton had
written to his friend Charles Dod,
this letter was written at nearly the
same time that Milton was writing lists at
us. Um, he wrote a, and this too
is in the packet. Um, he wrote,
listen to your body,
but in secret less dye blush.
And let me talk to you
grandiloquently for awhile.
You ask what I am thinking,
so help me God and immortality of fame
and we would we read. Can you
imagine getting such a letter? Uh,
Milton may well blush at this
extraordinary confession.
He is courting poetic fame
more shamelessly at this
point in his career than he
has before and perhaps that he will after.
But,
but the death of Edward King is really
forcing him to question the point of,
of his pursuit of, of
greatness, a poetic fame.
All of his ambition and the
poem continues at line 70.
Fame is the spur that the clear spirit
death rays that last infirmity of noble
mind to scorn,
delights and live laborious days.
But the fair Gerden when we hope to find
and think to burst out into a sudden
blaze comes the blind fury with the m
Horridge sheers and slits the thin spawn
life. It's the, it's the pursuit of fame,
the noble pursuit of fame
that spurs us to scorn,
delights and to live laborious days.
Uh,
as theme spurs us to pursue
the abstinent life of the poet,
it's the, it's the garden, the reward,
the prize of fame that we're continually
anticipating will burst out someday in
the, in a sudden blaze of glory. But
as soon as we hope to find that garden,
the golden ring comes the blind
fury with the imported sheers,
ouch.
And slits the thin spawn life.
The blind fury here is
the mythological figure,
a trope os this is the fate that cuts
the slender thread by which our lives
dangle and Milton Lens especial horror,
I think, to this image of a blind fury.
And I, I, I hope you will agree with
those critics. I didn't make this up.
Who find embedded in these lines
something like a figurative intimation of,
of castration,
like the furious Buckeye,
the furious eight [inaudible] emasculates
the man who dares to aspire to poetic
greatness with the Aborad sheers.
She cruelly punishes the virgin poet for
his failure to use the a and the one on
the one hand to use the sexual body
that God has endowed him with. Um,
but you also have the image
here of the poets death.
You have the image of the cutting
off the castration of the power of
generativity, all poetic potency, all,
all power to assert oneself
in the world can be severed,
uh, and, and, and the, and that's it.
And I don't think that the critics whose
who see here an image of castration or
just imagining it because there is
such a weird and just such a persistent
interest in the, in the human body and
especially in the poet's body throughout,
throughout this poem,
Milton's focus on the body,
on the entire realm of the corporeal.
Um,
I'm hoping that it feels a little
strange to you. It, and it seems strange,
I think when you consider
what is obviously here,
the Christian context, uh, of, of,
of Milton Solicitous Orthodox Christianity
teaches us to put aside our concerns
for the body when we consider our death.
The Old Testament Prophet had said,
all flesh is grass and
important verse for the new,
uh,
the new dispensation of Christianity.
And the only thing that matters is
the salvation of the incorporeal.
Pauriol the body lists soul.
But Milton is so unorthodox,
or at least Hetero docs in his insistence
on the importance of the, of the body.
In this poem, look at the first
paragraph that begins at line one 32.
This passage, uh, Milton
asks the Sicilian Muse.
This is the muse of pastoral poetry,
asks the Muse to help him
strew the flowers, um,
over the hearse to strew with flowers.
The casket in which
listed as his body lies,
that the body of listed as even in death
is of an unusual interest to our poet
and the speaker employees.
This is an amazingly physical,
and I think it's even essential language
as he catalogs the flowers that he
imagines we'll cover,
listened to says body line one 35.
You valley's low,
where the mild whispers use of shades
and wanton wins and gushing Brooks on is
fresh lap.
The Swartz star sparely
looks throw hither.
All your quaint enameled dies that on
the green turf suck the honeyed showers.
Okay. Maybe the, maybe the elder
brother and comments was wrong.
The virgin his body.
Can't you remember that
amazing counterfactual
fantasy the virgins body can't
make perhaps worse. We're,
we're, we're acknowledging here,
can't be transmuted into spirit or soul,
but we can still tend,
we can nurse the dead body.
We can love lovingly care for it and
ornamented here and are very corporeal way
on earth.
It's an intensely erotic
passage decorating this image
of decorating king's tomb
with flowers and it's at the height of
this vision of our floral decoration of
listed as is her birth
that the speaker is suddenly
caught up short. Look,
look at line one 54 w we read
line one 54 and we realize we've,
we have been had, we'd have
just, we've been sucked in.
We have just participated in one of the
biggest cheats that poetry can offer.
I me,
the speaker cries in one 54 I me,
he says as he realizes,
of course there will be no flowers.
There's not going to be a hearse.
Why not? There's no body. There's
no body to decorate. What have,
what have you been thinking
listed us was drowned.
His remains are unrecoverable.
This is a terrible moment of realization
on the part of the speaker whilst the,
the shores and sounding sees wash
far away where I, I bones are hurled,
whether it be on the stormy Hebrides
where thou perhaps under the overwhelming
tide visits the bottom
of the monstrous world.
Milton's confronting here the, the awful
fact that lizard is his bones. They,
they'd been hurled to
the four corners of the,
of the sounding sees
they could be anywhere.
And as if that weren't terrible enough,
a realization he goes on to vision and
even more grotesque and four listed as
his body. He conjures surely
this is in decorous. This is, uh,
this is wildly inappropriate,
I think in,
in such a pious poem,
the in decorist image of the dead listed
as under the whelming tied visiting the
bottom of the monsters seats.
That word visit that gets me,
that gets me every time.
It's so inappropriate and ghoulish I
think in in this already sufficiently
ghoulish context, it's,
well, first of all,
it's like a parody of the epic journey
to the underworld that we have in so many
great classical texts.
And it forces us to think at least
for a moment here of listed us as some
ghastly underwater visitor,
a skeletal monstrous version of,
of Jacques Cousteau peering
into the unknowable, monstrous,
mysterious depths of
the bottom of the world.
This intensely intimate focus on the
human body is out of place and a Christian
analogy and it's,
and this of course Milton nose,
and it's because the investment
in the bodily world is,
is so great here that Milton ultimately
turns to the Christian vision,
the more familiar Christian
vision of a body Euless afterlife.
And this is how this logic goes.
We are all familiar with this.
Our body remains to molder in the
earth or welter in the ocean where air,
but our incorporeal spirit rises to heaven
where it can enjoy and a theorial of
body lists world of
eternity. And so Milton, uh,
concludes listed us with this standard
vision of Christian constellation.
This is on some level.
This is textbook Protestant
or Catholic Christianity weep.
No more willful shepherds
weep no more for listened to.
See your sorrow is not dead sunk
though he be beneath the watery floor,
so sinks the day star in the ocean bed
and yet a non repairs is drooping head.
This image of the afterlife
is is founded on the Orthodox,
a figure of for eternity.
The body stays to the earth while the
soul like the daystar rises to the sky.
But when you, when you look a little
more closely at this conclusion,
I think you realized that Milton's
heaven is almost as invested in the human
body as Milton's earth had been
that they haven't imagined.
Here is is able actually to supply us in
fact with a better body than the one we
had down here.
When the speaker writes that the daystar
star yet a non repairs is drooping head.
We reminded of Orpheus.
We have an image here of a reconstituted
the repaired body of Orpheus who's
gory.
Severed head had been sent down the
swift Hebrews to the lesbian shore.
It's as if Milton can't let go of this
most unchristian attachment to the human
body.
And I think it's fair to say that Milton
can't really imagine or fully invest
himself in the Christian heaven until
he can fully corporealize it and imagine
it modeling. And this is exactly of
course what he will do in paradise.
Lost everyone in Milton's haven't
has a body. Even God himself,
the God himself in paradise
lost says nothing but body.
His body is the universe itself.
Listen,
listen to the physicality of the rest
of the description of Milton's haven't
enlisted us.
This is line one 72.
So listen to this sunk glow,
but mounted high through the deer might
have him that walked the waves where
other groves and other streams
along with nectar pure is Uzi locks.
He leaves and here's the unexpressed have
nuptial song in the blessed kingdoms,
meek of the joy and love their,
entertain him all the saints above and
solemn troops and sweet societies that
sing and singing in their glory move and
wipe the tears forever from his eyes.
Clearly the other groves in the
other streams are, are different. Um,
in, in heaven, uh, there, there, there,
there are different from the groves
and streams we have down here,
but they don't seem necessarily to defer.
I submit in their degree of physicality.
Listen,
this is going to shampoo his hair and
heaven much as he shampooed his hair on
earth except in heaven, there's
always a difference. Um,
it will be a nectar pure with
which he leaves his Uzi locks.
And even more important, uh, listed us.
We'll continue to sing in heaven
just as he had sung on earth,
except now he can hear the unexpressed
live that means inexpressible nuptial
song. We, we remember this song,
this is the song mentioned in revelation
14 that Milton is continually alluding
to. And we saw him allude to just
this passage ad pod trim. Uh,
John The divine had
written in revelation 14.
You know this and they sung as it were,
a new song before the throne.
And no man could learn that song,
but the hundred and 40 and 4,000,
which were redeemed from the earth,
these are they,
which were not defiled with women,
for they are virgins
and it's virgin. Who, who,
who get to sing the nuptial song at
the wedding of the lamb that John also
envisions Milton can't allow himself
to embrace the wonderful fiction that
beautiful fiction that had been
espoused by the elder brother.
The fantasy that virgin is don't even die.
That their bodies are simply
reconstituted somehow as angelic spirits.
That that was, that was, that
went too far. It was to pagan, uh,
way to unorthodox.
But Milton does permit himself the closest
scriptural version of that fiction.
And that's John's image in revelation
14 of the special heavenly rewards for
virgin poets.
Now,
you also looked at for today,
the Latin poem that Milton wrote
not long after licit us. Um,
that's the poem.
Damon's epitaph,
the Epitaph Iom Day Mona's written on
the very sad occasion of the death of
Milton's friend, best friend Charles
Dia Dadi who died the next year,
1638 that you remember,
this is the,
this is the young fellow that
Milton had confessed his,
his desire for a mortal fame to
look at the end of that poem.
This is page one 39 in the Hughes.
This is where Milton imagines
you have to turn to this.
He imagines dod just as he had imagined,
Edward King enjoying at last,
his heavenly reward.
And this is the English translation
because the poem is in Latin
because you loved the blush of
modesty and to stainless youth.
And because you did not taste the
delight of the marriage bed low,
the rewards of virginity
are reserved for you.
Your glorious head shall be bound with a
shining crown and with shadowing fronds
of joy as poems in your hand,
you enact your part eternally in the
immortal marriage where song and the sound
of the liar.
Can you even believe
what I'm about to say?
Where song in the sound of the liar are
mingled and ecstasy with blessed dances
and where the festal orgies
range under the heavenly thesis.
We, we, we know, we recognize
the song. This is the,
this is the song from revelation of the
virgin who could learn and seeing the
new song before the throne,
the throne of the Lord.
But Milton has obviously taken John's
image here and exploded the implications
of, of its erotic potential. Um, it's,
it's not just that virgin
virgin virgins are entitled, uh,
to sing a heavenly song.
As Milton is saying,
Dia Dadi is the heavenly reward in this
poem involves all of the sensuality,
all of the central experience that
was denied and repressed on earth.
This,
this Damon's epitaph ends
with a virtual orgasm of,
of Christian constellation as Milton
gives his best friend the most,
the most unbelievable send off that
is possible to give the heaven in.
This poem is so far from
being the Incor Pauriol,
the spiritual heaven of a,
of Orthodox Christianity,
that you have an image of an actual orgy,
the festal orgy raging under the thesis.
That's the Phallic Wand who's holding
this one? Presumably none other than the,
than the orgiastic leader God himself.
There's no other way to interpret
these lines, which as you can imagine,
critic simply, uh, pretend
don't exist because who, who,
who can,
who can figure out what to say?
Lou enlisted as Milton doesn't
let him himself, thank God,
go quite so far as he does in the,
this amazing ending to the,
to Damon's epitaph. And in fact, nowhere,
nowhere else do we see Milton
literally bursting out at the scenes,
um, as, uh, as, as he seems
to in this poem. But the,
but the unmistakable physicality of the
heaven imagined in the poem about Dhea.
Dadi gives us some idea,
I think of how to read by the end of
listed as the corporeal city of Damon's
epitaph illuminates.
We can see the,
the unorthodox direction in which
meals Milton's Melissa is tending.
So let me conclude,
let me conclude here.
Milton has wrenched this poem
away from Christianity and,
and he's forced it into a
direction that we could,
that we could loosely call paganism.
And it has been a slippage from Christian
spirituality into something like a
pagan naturalism. And it's a world
in which all things are physical.
All spirits,
like the genius Loci are physical,
palpable presences in the natural
world that the human body,
the world of flesh and blood that we all
inhabit have having some way at the end
of this poem reasserted themselves.
And in this final assertion of the body,
Milton,
I think is able to recover his,
his theodicy, his attempt to justify
the ways of God here on earth. Milton's,
Milton's listened. This is body
is still in some way a physical,
a physical one. And to the extent that
listed as his body has been recovered,
that it's been redeemed, Milton
is able, perhaps successfully,
Milton is able to justify
the ways of God to man.
He's able to justify the ways of
God to men here on the physical,
on this intimately bodily earth
listed as this is the last
thing I will tell you, as, as,
as you have no doubt experience,
this is a dense and difficult poem.
So please reread it,
um, in numerable times for the, for
the, for, for Wednesday's class.
And in addition to that, do the
other readings assigned. Okay.